Und jetzt haben wir grosse Angst ...
... dass Oma und Opa sterben.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Für viele Ukrainerinnen
in der Schweiz
sind diese Tage der blanke Horror.
Sie bangen
um ihre Familie und Freunde,
die im Kriegsgeschehen gefangen sind.
Meine Seele schmerzt -
und das bleibt für immer.
Und das ist meine Schwester Anya.
Sie wird im Bunker gebären.
Dort gibt es für das Kind
keine Chance, zu überleben.
Wir von "rec."
haben Familien begleitet,
die versuchen, ihre Liebsten
zu sich in Sicherheit zu bringen.
In solchen Momenten
wird es schwierig.
Es ist gut, wenn man etwas in die
Hände nehmen und organisieren kann.
Ich treffe gleich Alona.
Sie ist in der Schweiz,
ihre Familie in der Ukraine.
Ihre Schwester
ist im neunten Monat schwanger.
Sie ist irgendwo
in einem Bunker oder Keller.
Sie kann nicht flüchten.
Sie kann nicht einmal zur Grenze.
Ich möchte wissen, wie sie
mit ihrer Schwester in Kontakt steht
und wie sie mit der Situation umgeht.
Bevor ich mich auf den Weg machte,
hatte ich mich gefragt,
ob es okay ist, Menschen
in akuten Situationen zu filmen.
Ist das nicht voyeuristisch?
Auf der Redaktion diskutierten wir
und sind der Meinung,
dass es vertretbar ist.
Alona und ihre Familie
haben sich das Ganze gut überlegt.
Bei ihnen zu Hause
öffnet Alonas Mann Longin die Tür.
Alona selber füttert gerade
ihre kleine Tochter Michelle.
Alona ist seit sieben Jahren
in der Schweiz.
Sie wuchs in Charkiw auf.
Das ist nach Kiew
die zweitgrösste Stadt in der Ukraine
und liegt an der Grenze zu Russland.
Charkiw ist zum Zeitpunkt des Drehs
stark unter Beschuss.
Ihre Familie steckt fest,
es scheint keinen Ausweg zu geben.
Erst kann ich gar nicht
mit Alona sprechen.
Sie wird ständig angerufen
und versucht,
sich einen Überblick
über die Lage zu machen.
Was kannst du tun,
um sie zu unterstützen?
In erster Linie,
kümmere ich mich um Michelle,
kaufe ein, koche.
Ich halte ihr so gut es geht
den Rücken frei.
Und ja, das machen wir.
Und ab und zu umarmen,
wenn ich merke,
dass es schwierig ist.
Für Michelle
soll der Alltag weitergehen,
auch wenn sich ihre Eltern
in einem Ausnahmezustand befinden.
Die Aufnahmen ihrer Heimatstadt
Charkiw belasten Alona sehr.
Das ist von heute.
Das war ein wunderschönes ...
... Haus.
Ein historischer Platz.
Was soll man fühlen,
wenn man ...
... ein Geburtshaus so sieht?
Was soll man fühlen?
Das ist alles Charkiw.
Ich kann nicht verifizieren,
woher die Videos genau stammen,
sehe aber, was sie mit Alona machen.
Das ist unsere Hochzeit.
Und das ist meine Schwester Anya.
Sie ist 37.
Wann hast du das letzte Mal
von ihr gehört?
Heute ...
Heute Morgen schrieb ich ihr:
"Bist du am Leben?"
Das ist ein Wort.
Nach einer Weile antwortete sie mir:
"Ja, wir sind am Leben."
Diese Tage
waren sie die ganze Zeit im Bunker.
Nur im Bunker.
Es könnte also sein,
dass sie im Bunker gebären muss.
Ja.
Es kann auch sein,
dass sie überlebt ...
Sie wird auch im Bunker gebären.
Dort gibt es für das Kind
keine Chance, zu überleben.
Es ist kalt,
es ist feucht, es ist ...
Es ist kein Leben.
Mitten im Interview
ruft Alonas Schwester an.
Hallo?
Sie ist in Charkiw und hat sich lange
geweigert, die Heimat zu verlassen.
Sie sagte immer: "Ich bin Patriotin
und ich bleibe hier."
"Warum sagst du,
ich solle zu dir kommen?"
"Dass ich diese Zeit
bei dir warten soll?"
Jetzt sagt sie ...
Sie fragte mich gerade,
ob es irgendwie möglich sei,
sie abzuholen.
Sie meinte,
sie habe heute so geweint.
Das Kind sei so unruhig.
Den ganzen Tag ...
... war es unruhig
und bewegte sich stark.
Sie sagte, sie wisse nicht,
warum sie so viel weine.
Ob langsam die Zeit komme ...
Sie wisse nicht,
was sie machen soll.
Ihr versucht,
wie ein Schlupfloch zu finden,
damit ihr die Eltern
und deine Schwester holen könnt?
Das nicht. Das nicht.
Das ist unrealistisch.
Ich bereite mich darauf vor,
dass ich sie nicht sehen werde.
Oder nie mehr.
Ja, das ist so.
Das tut mir leid.
- Aber das ist nicht deine Schuld.
Ich glaube, es ist wichtig,
die Hoffnung nicht zu verlieren.
Das Leben geht weiter für sie.
Für sie schon,
aber es gibt viele Kinder wie sie,
die keine Eltern haben werden.
Oder Eltern, die nicht mehr da sind.
Glückliches Mädchen.
Sie ist glücklich
und kann nicht verstehen,
weshalb Mama
in letzter Zeit nervös ist
und keine Zeit für sie hat.
Alona und Longin
sind eine der Familien,
mit denen wir für diese Reportage
in Kontakt sind.
Wir haben unzählige Mails
von Menschen erhalten,
die um ihre Liebsten bangen
und erzählen,
was sie und ihre Familie
in der Ukraine durchmachen.
Jemand schreibt:
Oder: "Meine Schwester
und ihre Familie leben in Kiew."
"Sie sind auf der Flucht
und sitzen in Riwne
auf dem Weg in den Westen fest."
Familienmitglieder in der Ukraine
versuchen,
aus Städten wie Kiew,
Charkiw oder Mariupol zu flüchten
und irgendwie rauszukommen.
Es ist nicht ganz einfach,
da Brücken gesprengt wurden,
Strassen nicht mehr befahrbar sind
und sie Routen ändern müssen.
Es ist überhaupt nicht planbar,
an welcher Grenze
und wann sie ankommen werden.
Viele Familien wollen ihre Verwandten
bei sich in der Schweiz
in Sicherheit bringen.
Dafür müssen sie es aber durch das
Kriegsgebiet an die Grenze schaffen.
Dadurch ändert sich die Situation
auch für Familien in der Schweiz
fast im Stundentakt.
Immer wieder
sind Menschen an der Grenze
oder sie haben Kontakt
mit Menschen an der Grenze,
die im Stau stehen
und verschiedene Grenzübergänge
in Betracht ziehen.
Was vorherrscht, ist
eine grosse Angst um die Angehörigen,
und die Ungewissheit,
ob sie es an die Grenze schaffen.
Die Angst besteht auch
bei Nataliia und ihrem Mann,
einer Familie,
die sich bei mir meldete.
Die beiden
kommen ursprünglich aus Kiew,
leben aber seit 13 Jahren
in der Schweiz.
Ihre Eltern sind noch in der Ukraine.
Nataliia schrieb mir, dass
ihre Eltern durch die Ukraine fahren,
um aus dem Land zu kommen.
An welche Grenze sie fahren
und wann sie ankommen werden,
ist momentan nicht klar.
Sicher ist aber, dass Nataliias Mann
Yaroslav quasi auf Abruf ist,
um möglichst schnell loszufahren,
wenn die Eltern an der Grenze sind.
Es ging plötzlich schnell.
Es hiess eigentlich, dass Nataliias
Mann erst in zwei Tagen
an die ukrainische Grenze
fahren würde.
Vorhin schickte sie mir ein Video,
dass ihr Mann alles stehen
und liegen liess und den Bus packe,
um möglichst schnell loszufahren.
Offenbar sind Nataliias Eltern
bald an der Grenze
und er möchte sie
in Sicherheit bringen.
Ich mache mich auf den Weg
nach Schlatt zu Nataliia,
denn sie bleibt
mit den drei Kindern zu Hause.
Ich möchte wissen,
wie sie mit der Situation umgeht.
Als ich 30 Min. später
in Schlatt/TG ankomme,
steht der Bus
schon nicht mehr in der Einfahrt.
Yaroslav wollte nicht mehr warten.
Er möchte so schnell wie möglich
an die rumänische Grenze
und hofft,
auf seine Schwiegereltern zu treffen.
Kaum durch die Tür,
zeigt mir Nataliia das Video.
Man sieht ihren Mann,
der die Abfahrt vorbereitet
und das Auto mit Hilfsgütern belädt.
Geplant ist,
dass er sie an die Grenze bringt
und gleichzeitig
Nataliias Eltern abholt.
Wie ist es für dich,
wenn deine Eltern in der Ukraine sind
und du nichts machen kannst?
Es geht nicht nur um meine Eltern,
sondern auch um Freunde
und um eine Freundin von mir.
Ich habe keinen Kontakt mehr zu ihr.
Ich habe
mehrere Personen kontaktiert
und weiss nicht,
ob sie und ihre Tochter noch leben.
Und meine Eltern ...
Mein Vater z.B. hatte in der Nacht
schwere Herzprobleme.
Er konnte nicht ins Krankenhaus.
Ich wusste nicht,
ob er überleben würde.
Und ja, das macht alles ...
Ich weiss nicht ...
Ich war energielos.
Manchmal war ich so wütend,
dass ich bereit war,
in die ukrainische Armee zu gehen.
Aber ich habe selber drei Kinder.
Das ist meine Priorität:
Erst muss ich mich um sie kümmern.
Dann kann ich den anderen helfen.
Sie versucht,
von zu Hause aus zu helfen.
Vor ein paar Tagen
machte sie einen Aufruf auf Facebook.
Nun bringen Nachbarn und Bekannte
Spenden für die Ukraine vorbei.
Was ihr Mann nicht mitnehmen konnte,
bringt Nataliia zur Botschaft.
Die sinnvolle Aufgabe lenkt sie
von ihren grossen Sorgen ab.
Auch die Solidarität
ist eine grosse Stütze.
Hoi.
Geht dein Mann in die Ukraine?
Er ist schon gefahren.
- Schon?
Ja.
- Wir haben noch einen Schlafsack.
Danke.
Die hat meine Mutter nie benutzt.
Super, danke sehr.
- Wanderschuhe.
Und mein Militärschlafsack.
- Oh, ein Militärschlafsack sogar.
Danke.
- Falls der etwas bringt.
Super.
Und ich dachte,
statt der Glückskette zu spenden,
könnt ihr das irgendwo einsetzen.
Für Lebensmittel oder sonst etwas.
- Danke. Danke.
Darf ich dich umarmen?
- Kein Problem.
Danke.
Wenig später kommen Nataliias Töchter
aus der Schule.
Nur einige Minuten später
klingelt es wieder.
Ein Schulfreund der Töchter
bringt einige Pullover
für Kinder in der Ukraine.
Nataliia spricht mit ihren Mädchen
bewusst über den Krieg.
Sie will, dass sie wissen,
weshalb die Eltern so traurig sind.
Und jetzt haben wir grosse Angst ...
... dass Oma und Opa sterben
oder etwas Schlimmes passiert.
Oder die ...
Oder die Bösen
an unsere Grenzen kommen.
Zur Angst um die Grosseltern
kommt jetzt auch die
um den Vater und Ehemann,
der die lange Fahrt
Richtung Kriegsgebiet auf sich nimmt.
Ich habe in erster Linie Angst,
weil er so weit fahren muss.
Wir haben in den letzten Nächten
nicht gut geschlafen.
Er nahm ganz viele Koffeintabletten.
Ich rufe ihn auch ab und zu an,
um zu fragen, wie es ihm geht,
und um sicherzustellen,
dass er anhält
und sich ein wenig ausruht.
Zwei Tage nach unserem Treffen
melde ich mich bei Alona.
Sie schickte mir eine Nachricht:
Ihre Schwester und deren Mann
schafften es aus Charkiw.
Hallo.
Der Mann meiner Schwester ...
... wird die Ukraine
nicht verlassen.
Nein,
er wird in der Ukraine bleiben.
Sein Ziel ist aber,
sie zur Grenze zu bringen.
Die Frage ist jetzt, wie.
Ob er es schafft oder bereits vorher
ins Militär einrücken muss?
Genau.
Die Situation ist für sie klar:
Sie werden einander
wahrscheinlich nicht wiedersehen.
Und das Kind ...
... wird den Vater nie ...
Aber hoffen wir,
dass alles gut wird.
Ja.
Ich bewundere dich sehr -
wie stark du in dieser Situation
bist und bleibst.
Das Leid der Menschen,
die wir begleiten,
beschäftigt uns
auch nach dem Dreh sehr -
im Wissen, dass sich noch
ganz andere Schicksale abspielen.
Im Büro verfolgen wir den Krieg
aus sicherer Entfernung.
Die Nachrichten überschlagen sich.
Wer das nicht selber erlebt,
kann kaum nachvollziehen,
was im Osten Europas passiert.
Immer mehr Zivilisten und
Zivilistinnen verlieren ihr Zuhause,
sogar ihr Leben oder sind
auf der Flucht in ein fremdes Land.
Und das möglichst schnell -
wie Nataliias Eltern.
Sie starteten vor drei Tagen in Kiew
und fahren nun ununterbrochen
mit dem Auto Richtung Grenze -
durch ein Land,
in dem Krieg herrscht.
Noch ist unklar,
wann sie auf Yaroslav treffen,
doch sie sind zuversichtlich.
Good News gibt es inzwischen
auch bei der zweiten Familie.
Ich bin auf dem Weg zu Alona
und Longin.
Longin hat entschieden,
noch heute nach Polen zu fahren,
um Alonas Schwester abzuholen.
Alona bleibt zu Hause,
um nach Michelle zu schauen.
Als ich komme,
ist Longin am Aufbrechen.
... habe ich im Portemonnaie dabei.
Mehr brauche ich nicht.
Wasser haben wir, Geld ...
Den Pass habe ich kontrolliert,
die Adressen habe ich.
Es ist sehr schwierig -
für dich zum Fahren
und auch für mich.
Michelle, du passt auf Mama auf!
Es ist schwierig,
mich im Griff zu haben
und meine Gefühle nicht zu zeigen.
Jetzt denke ich so.
Und wenn es da ist ...
Ja, ja!
Tschau.
Tschau, tschau.
Okay. Tschau, Schatz. Ui, ui, ui.
Tschüss.
Bis bald. Wir hören uns unterwegs.
Bye-bye.
- Tschau.
Longin wird einen Mitfahrer aufgabeln
und via Deutschland
ins polnische Krakau fahren.
Dort holt er Anya
und fünf weitere Frauen ab,
die mit dem Bus
über die Grenze kommen sollten.
Darf ich fragen:
Du warst die ganze Zeit sehr stark
und machst das jetzt alles.
Wie fühlst du dich?
Ich war nicht immer stark.
Man meint immer,
man sei stark und cool.
Das bin ich auch meistens -
also, das meint man.
Aber in dieser Situation
sind meine Nerven
auch nicht immer beieinander.
Aber es gibt einige Menschen,
die sich auf uns verlassen.
Deshalb müssen wir das tun.
Longin sorgt sich sehr um
seine hochschwangere Schwägerin Anya.
Als Vater weiss er, welchen Stellen-
wert die Geburt eines Kindes hat.
Ich erinnere mich
an den Tag von Michelles Geburt.
Ich stand am Morgen auf,
glasklares Wetter.
Ich fuhr auf den Zollikerberg,
weisse Schneeberge im Hintergrund.
Es herrschte
eine unglaubliche Stimmung.
Wunderschön, wie im Bilderbuch.
Heute dachte ich an Anya
und was sie erleben muss.
Da kommt dir einfach das Kotzen.
In solchen Momenten
wird es schwierig.
Es ist gut, wenn man etwas in die
Hände nehmen und organisieren kann.
Für mich endet hier die Fahrt,
damit ich niemandem
einen Platz wegnehme.
Hier steigt der Beifahrer zu.
Sie wechseln sich beim Fahren ab.
Es ist so absurd,
dass ich einfach aussteigen
und nach Hause gehen kann,
während Longin nach Polen fährt,
um Anya zu holen.
Er wirkte gestresst.
Er hat den Plan vor Augen und
muss an vieles gleichzeitig denken.
Er ist aber auch nervös.
Anya fuhr die letzten Tage
stehend Zug - und noch immer -,
um über die Grenze zu kommen.
Man weiss nicht, wie es ihr geht:
mental, psychisch,
aber auch physisch,
und wie es dem Kind geht.
Wie es ist,
wenn die ganze Anspannung wegfällt.
Für mich ist unvorstellbar,
was sie alles durchmachen.
Und wie alles kommen wird,
ist noch offen.
Anders bei Nataliias Familie.
Dort gibt es positive Neuigkeiten.
Dein Mann ist jetzt
mit deinen Eltern an der Grenze.
Ja, genau.
Die Nachrichten sind so:
Mein Mann ist nach 24 Std.
endlich in Rumänien an der Grenze
angekommen.
Ich hörte, dass sie total müde sind,
aber auch ...
Sie können jetzt etwas aufatmen,
da sie herkommen.
Ich kann auch aufatmen.
Bald kommen sie.
Gut, tschüss, Caro.
- Tschüss, Nataliia.
Mehr als 48 Std. später
fahre ich nach Schlatt,
wo ich eine aufgeregte Familie
antreffe.
* Nataliia spricht ukrainisch. *
Er kommt, er kommt!
* Sie jubeln. *
Im Auto sitzen aber nur Yaroslav
und die Grossmutter, ihre Babuschka.
Nataliias Vater und Mutter
leben getrennt.
Ihr Vater
fuhr mit seiner neuen Partnerin
zu Nataliias Halbschwester nach Genf.
Schau, deine Babuschka.
Ich merke,
dass ein Teil der Anspannung weg ist,
doch Babuschka kann die Situation
noch nicht richtig fassen.
Sie wirkt erschöpft
und gedanklich sehr abwesend.
Auch Yaroslav ist mit seinen Gedanken
noch in der Ukraine -
auch wegen seiner Eltern.
Er musste sie dort zurücklassen,
denn sie wollen bleiben
und ihr Haus ausserhalb von Kiew
nicht verlassen.
Wie geht es dir jetzt?
- Super.
Super, es ist der erste Tag,
an dem ich aufatmen kann.
Ich würde es so sagen:
75 % sehr gut.
Ich bin begeistert und sehr happy,
aber zu 25 %
bin ich noch immer in der Ukraine -
bei meinen Freundinnen und Freunden.
Meine Seele schmerzt -
und das bleibt für immer.
Ja ...
Ich glaube, das Gefühl, das Nataliia
und ihre Kinder und Familie hatten,
als Babuschka aus dem Auto stieg ...
Die Freude, die sie hatten ...
... ist unbeschreiblich
und nicht in Worte zu fassen.
Das spürte man.
Gleichzeitig weiss man,
dass das einfach eine Familie ist,
die es geschafft hat,
ein Beispiel,
aber es gibt ganz viele andere ...
... die ...
... dieses Glück nicht haben,
dass sie rauskommen ...
... und Familien auf sie warten.
Glück - wenn man das
in dieser Situation sagen kann -
hat auch Alonas Familie.
Eineinhalb Tage nachdem ihr Mann
Richtung Polen aufbrach,
bekomme ich ein Update.
Um 13 Uhr
konnte sie die Grenze überqueren.
Sie war 12 Std. an der Grenze.
Es war relativ okay,
da sie im Bus gesessen hatten.
Aber sie sagte auch,
dass es viele Menschen gab,
die die ganze Zeit
draussen gestanden hatten.
Und viele Babys.
Es ist unglaublich kalt.
Bei uns ist es frisch, dort kalt.
Ich glaube, für sie war es wie ...
Man kann wieder durchatmen oder ...
Sie ist gerettet. Also, tschüss!
- Tschüss.
Anya ist in Sicherheit.
Sie ist bei Longin angekommen.
Es ging alles viel länger
als geplant.
Sie kann kaum abwarten,
dass Anya endlich nach Hause kommt.
Es sollte heute Nacht
irgendwann so weit sein.
Ich bin auf dem Weg zu Alona.
Ihre Schwester
könnte jede Minute ankommen.
Ich bin selber auch gespannt,
wie es wird.
Ich denke, es wird megaschön,
wenn die beiden aufeinandertreffen.
Als ich ankomme, zeigt mir Alona,
dass sie alles vorbereitet hat -
für ihre Schwester
und die anderen ukrainischen Frauen,
die Longin aus Polen mitbringt.
Das ist Michelles Zimmer.
Hier schlafen alle.
Nicht so cool ...
... aber trotzdem ist es besser,
als im Bunker zu sitzen.
Es ist v.a. sicherer.
Plötzlich hören wir das Auto.
* Alona spricht ukrainisch. *
Hoi. Es ist gut jetzt.
* Sie sprechen ukrainisch. *
Die Frauen treffen
in ihrem vorübergehenden Zuhause ein.
Sie sind gezeichnet von der Flucht.
Die Blumen schenkte ihnen
Longin übrigens zum Weltfrauentag.
Der hochschwangeren Anya geht es
den Umständen entsprechend gut.
Morgen hat sie für Abklärungen
einen Termin bei der Frauenärztin.
Um den Frauen Zeit zu lassen,
spreche ich mit Longin.
Er erzählt mir
von der Situation in Polen.
Ich sage es auf Deutsch,
damit meine Frau alles versteht.
Für mich war es beeindruckend
und bedrückend,
als ich gestern Nacht
am Bahnhof von Krakau sah,
wie viele Flüchtlinge
dort am Boden sitzen,
mit Babys, mit Neugeborenen -
einfach voll in der Scheisse.
Als ich sie abholte -
es war 5 Uhr -, dachte ich:
"Sie sind die Glücklichen."
"Sie haben jemanden, der sie abholt
und in ein warmes Zimmer bringt."
Aber was machen die anderen?
Was sie erleben, ist die Ausnahme.
Was mir auch auffiel:
Ich dachte, wir bräuchten
ein grosses Auto mit viel Platz.
Doch sie kommen mit Tüten, alles
andere mussten sie dort lassen.
Man nimmt nur das eigene Leben mit.
Das ist kein Witz.
Das tut man nicht freiwillig.
Wie war es für sie,
an die Grenze zu kommen?
Kann sie das erzählen?
* Alona übersetzt auf Ukrainisch. *
Magst du sie fragen,
wie der Abschied von ihrem Mann war?
Oder lieber nicht?
Es würde noch viel mehr zu erzählen geben.
Ich will aber niemanden länger beanspruchen.
Was Anya gesagt hat, beschäftigt mich .
-Im Auto hab ich sie gefragt, ob Sergei glücklich ist, dass sie nun weg ist.
Da hat sie gesagt, nein, überhaupt nicht. Einfach, weil sie jetzt weg ist.
Sie ist jetzt zwar in Sicherheit, aber glücklich? Nein!
Es war eine sehr spezielle Stimmung bei ihnen daheim.
Alona hat sich sehr gefreut, das war stark spürbar.
Es ist einfach sehr beeindruckend, wie sie die Situation meistern.
Wie sie alles geben und immer noch an alle Anderen denken.
Es war Alona sehr wichtig zu betonen, dass es nicht
nur darum geht, ihre Familie zu retten. Sie möchte mehr tun
und mehr helfen. Aber leider sind ihr da die Hände gebunden.